[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
france a 24
rosa pérez más de esta lista con
nosotros para hablar de como el ataque
aéreo registrado esta noche en la franja
de gaza lo ha relatado y retratado la
prensa internacional que dice la agencia
de noticias palestina y como lo
contextualiza al yazira pues que sea
rosa parés masdéu como siempre que nos
diga esto rosa bienvenida muy buen día
buenos dias raúl como decías la agencia
palestina de noticias de información
wafa dice que según su corresponsal el
bombardeo israelí cayó en la ciudad del
sur de la franja de gaza jan yunís y que
de momento no se conocen víctimas
mortales del ataque dice esta nota el
ataque llegó después de que el sistema
antiaéreo cúpula de hierro de israel'
interceptar a un cohete lanzado desde la
franja de gaza que de momento nadie ha
reivindicado por otro lado al yazira
contextualiza este bombardeo israelí
y con lo que está pasando en jerusalén
dice israel ataca la franja de gaza
mientras la tensión aumenta en jerusalén
también añade este texto que el sitio
bombardeado por la fuerza por las
fuerzas israelís sería según las
autoridades de tel aviv una fábrica de
armamento de hamás y que también jamás
dijo que ya respondieron con misiles a
los aviones de los
aviones de las fuerzas sionistas y todo
esto como como decíamos en el contexto
de las incursiones y de las redadas de
la policía israelí en la mezquita de
al-aqsa y todo esto pues desata el temor
de que vuelva una ofensiva de la
magnitud de la del año pasado en la
franja de gaza y pasamos ahora a hablar
de rusia donde según reportó la agencia
bloomberg presidente ruso vladimir putin
e rosa condecoró la unidad acusada por
ucrania de supuestos crímenes de guerra
en lucha así es el presidente ruso firmó
ayer un decreto con el que otorgó a los
soldados de la brigada de infantería
motorizada números 4 el título de
guardianes por defender la madre patria
y los intereses del estado ruso también
el presidente putin alabó el coraje de
estos soldados en esta operación militar
especial así como lo llaman desde el
kremlin pero recordemos que esta unidad
precisamente está siendo investigada
tanto por la justicia ucraniana como por
la corte penal internacional por su
posible implicación en supuestos
crímenes de guerra en lucha recordemos
unas imágenes unas escenas que moscú con
si continúa considerando como un montaje
y por otro lado james beer world analiza
en el monstruo time las dificultades del
ejército ruso en su ofensiva en el
donbass en este momento activa exacto el
periodista de moscú times en este
análisis parte de la siguiente premisa y
es que el ejército ruso tendría en mente
hacer una operación pinza por y sium en
el norte y por mariupol en el sur en un
intento de sacar a las fuerzas
ucranianas de la región del donbass y
dar una victoria clave al presidente
vladimir putin para el 9 de mayo en
condecoración al día que el ejército
soviético
derrotó a los nazis pero que sin embargo
como comentas problemas de moral o de
suministros podrían dificultar estos
planes de las fuerzas rusas dice que si
bien son superiores no todavía las
fuerzas rusas al respecto a las
ucranianas estamos hablando en términos
numéricos es difícil establecer las
bajas humanas entre las filas puede ser
rusas sin embargo detalla cuáles han
sido las bajas materiales del ejército
ruso dice hasta ahora han perdido 510
tanques 2000 otros vehículos armados
blindados y cuatro buques y de momento
dice el ejército ruso continúa
intentando reclutar a hombres en donges
y lugansk bueno rosa y vamos a cerrar
esta revista de prensa con lo que
estábamos avanzando en nuestro titular
el escándalo ya conocido como el catalán
gate su tierra natal cataluña una
investigación de la organización sitios
en la pública new yorker en un reportaje
llamado como las democracias espían a
sus ciudadanos rosa qué está pasando con
el catalán gate bueno como decías esta
es una investigación que ha salido
publicada en esta revista estadounidense
en el 'new yorker' y de la que se han
hecho eco pues muchos medios
internacionales y que está pues
originada por esta organización
canadiense citizen lab viena como ha
dicho esta organización se trata de la
operación de espionaje más grande que
hayan conocido y se trata del espionaje
de unas 60 personalidades catalanas
tanto políticos de alto con altos cargos
como activistas vinculados con el
independentismo catalán y no sólo tiene
magnitud en términos de personas
espiadas sino también es que entre ellas
se encuentran el actual president de la
generalitat pere aragonès así como los
tres presidentes de cataluña precedentes
no zorra puigdemont o más todos pues con
sus grandes implicaciones con el
independentismo institucional viena
citizen lab en su investigación
directamente al gobierno español sino
que más bien apunta al centro nacional
de inteligencia de hecho el gobierno de
pedro sánchez ya se ha desmarcado de la
operación pero es que los distintos
casos de espionaje irían desde 2015
hasta 2021 por lo que comprenden tanto
al gobierno del conservador mariano
rajoy como al actual gobierno socialista
no tanto amnistía internacional como
bruselas como se acaba de conocer los
partidos independentistas catalanes ya
han pedido investigaciones en las
justicias de distintos países y para
terminar raúl en la prensa catalana
también encontramos esta información
destacada desde muchas aristas de hecho
el medio catalán vilaweb dice que es
imposible que los servicios de
inteligencia destinarán tantos recursos
a investigar pues a ciudadanos del país
sin que pues el gobierno estuviera al
corriente por lo que piden explicaciones
pues al gobierno de madrid rosa gracias
por toda la información es nueva mañana
con más de revista de prensa pasamos
ahora a los deportes rosa